- multiplied by what will give us 1 it
will be 1/2 2 multiplied by 1 over 2
will give us 1 and what multiplied by 6
will give us 1 1 over 6 what are these
two numbers called
each of them is a reciprocal of the
respective numbers 1/2 is the reciprocal
of 2 and 1 over 6 is a reciprocal of six
dozen matrix have a reciprocal let's say
we have matrix a in matrices the
identity matrix represents 1 or unity so
we can ask a multiplied by what will
give us I or the identity matrix yes
what can we have here such that the
product of these two matrices will give
us the identity matrix instead of
writing 1 over a we write something
called a inverse yes this is the inverse
of matrix a a with negative 1 as the
superscript and a times a inverse will
give us the identity matrix and what
multiplied by a will give us the
identity matrix again it's a inverse a
inverse times a will give us the
identity matrix this is the concept of
an inverse of matrix its product with a
will give us the identity matrix let's
look at an example on a new page B or
given matrix a it's a two-by-two matrix
and for this matrix a we are given a
inverse it equals this now we need to
check if their product gives us the
identity matrix on the left side we
multiply a with a inverse and on the
right we multiply a inverse with a
remember that matrices are non
commutative a times B may or may not
equal B times a we need to verify both
these products this is matrix a
multiplied by a inverse and this is a
inverse multiplied by matrix a we start
off by finding the product on the
left what will be the one one at element
it will equal the product of the first
row with the first column 2 times 1 plus
1 times minus 1 2 minus 1 for the 1 2
earth element we multiplied the first
row with the second column 2 times minus
1 plus 1 times 2 we get minus 2 plus 2
for the 2 one element we multiply the
second row with the first column 1
multiplied by 1 plus 1 multiplied by
minus 1 that will give us 1 minus 1 and
for the last element we multiply the
second row with the second column 1
multiplied by minus 1 plus 1 multiplied
by 2 minus 1 plus 2 now we just
calculate the 4 elements 2 minus 1 is 1
minus 2 plus 2 gives us 0 1 minus 1 is 0
and minus 1 plus 2 equals 1 yes we get
an identity matrix a times a inverse
gives us the identity matrix what about
this product why don't you pause the
video and find out what this product
gives us this is what we get this is the
first row multiplied with the first
column this is the first row multiplied
by the second column second times first
and second times second what do we get
after solving each 2 minus 1 is 1 1
minus 1 is 0 minus 2 plus 2 is 0 and
minus 1 plus 2 is 1 clearly an identity
matrix again both products give us the
identity matrix wait hold on finding the
reciprocals of numbers was easy but how
do we find the inverse of a matrix we
will cover that in the next few lessons